it has to be said that Michael Shannon's
character in this movie is probably one
of the coolest characters have seen all
year I don't know it also sent his intro
so just Michael Shannon nocturnal
animals so nocturnal animals is a movie
with it's a story within a story kind of
like a really messed-up version of
Princess Bride
it starts out Amy Adams has her posh
life with armie hammer the like
la-dee-da are did she gets a book from
her ex-husband in the mail called
nocturnal animals and so she reads it
and that's where it's a story within a
story and the story within the story is
a really tragic sad messed up dark ass
story that she's reading and she'll
close the book and go back to her and
show her life then it also flashes back
to her marriage to Jake Gyllenhaal years
prior it'll go back to the story so it
really is two different stories or three
phases of stories or possibly two actual
phases and one fictional story what I
like most of all the acting is pretty
great I already said my piece about
Michael Shannon Michael Shannon is a
character in the story within the story
in fact he's like the coolest character
there and say he's so hardcore and Rhys
I don't think Michael Shannon knew who's
being filmed he is just that Michael
Shannon Jake Gyllenhaal was great what
happens to his family in the story
within the story's a super super intense
stuff it's that white knuckling in the
theater like okay this is gonna go a
certain way I hope in the end it pays
off because it's gonna take me to a dark
spot in my soul and Amy Adams Amy Adams
has really been showing her stuff lately
I feel like between this and a rival
she's gonna get a nomination somewhere I
personally feel she was better in a
rival that's just me I know a lot of
people are just blowing loads over this
movie I think the movie is good I should
rephrase the movie is fascinating it's a
really captivating ass story with great
acting as to how this story within the
story actually fits in with the story is
it a metaphor is it actually what has
happened in this dude's life these are
the questions that people will plug
themselves with I'm very sure in true
internet fashion there is a theory out
there about how the story within the
story is some sort of metaphor for the
Manhattan Project is this now it's gonna
go down the bummer is didn't always fit
with me I know what the movie was trying
to do with the story within the story in
the story which is reading the book and
story of how it actually pertains to
life
lot of times I felt like alright the
story within the story of the two
stories is a far superior story to the
one word like the lady she's reading the
book I mean in reality if the story
within the story with the one with
Michael Shannon Jake Gyllenhaal and hold
that dynamic if that was just a movie
and there wasn't someone reading a book
reading that story this would have been
a fine movie I would have enjoyed the
hell out of it it would have been dark
as [ __ ] I would have enjoyed it how it
metaphorically weaves into the other
story is fine but it just didn't always
jell with me guys in the end nocturnal
animals was fascinating and interesting
great acting great premise of the story
within the story the division of the
story sometimes compromised the movie as
a whole for me I get what they were
trying to do with it and have parallels
metaphors I just feel like I could have
gone with story B and completely negated
story a I didn't care as much but in the
end I will say nocturnal animals is a
good time no alcohol required haunting s
movie you'll think about it for a bit
and that ain't bad alright guys some
nocturnal animals have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite story within a story among the
entirety of a movie and its story
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more